do you want to export your product to
the EU but aren't certain what rules to
follow
then the EU trade helpdesk is the
perfect tool for you here you'll find
all you need to know about the rules and
regulations and any customs duties
you'll need to pay let's say you want to
export cocoa butter from Ghana to France
first select your products country of
origin then choose your destination
country next you'll need to find the EU
product code for cocoa butter simply
click on find my product code and then
type cocoa butter in the search box once
you've got your product code click on
search now you'll see all the
information about exporting cocoa butter
to the EU separated into tabs first
there is import procedures this explains
the customs procedures you'll need to
follow for example the paperwork you'll
need to fill out second product
requirements here you'll find the health
safety and technical standards and the
labeling rules for your product then
there is import duties this will show
you the duty you'll have to pay a
customs including any discount you might
be eligible for we also show you any
other taxes that apply in the EU country
your exporting to as these affect the
final price of your product the rules of
origin help us define the economic
nationality of your product which is
important when you claim a duty discount
and lastly you'll also find how much of
your product the EU imports already and
from where information you may need for
your business plan
so with the EU trade helpdesk and your
great product you'll have all you need
to crack the world's biggest market
you